[MUSIC PLAYING]
JULIE ARANDA: Hi, everyone.
Welcome, and thank you for
coming to our talk today.
We are members of
the Android UX team.
And we're excited
today to talk to you
about the new
notifications features in O
from a UX perspective.
So I'm Julie, I'm a researcher
on the Android team.
And today, I'll first tell
you about the research
that inspired the new
notifications features in O.
So in November of
2015, our team went
on what we call a UX-pedition
to learn more about how people
experience notifications.
So our team of researchers,
designers, engineers, PMs--
we all spent a week in
New York and New Jersey
speaking to and observing users.
We approached the topic
as attention management
to include interruptions
from devices,
other people around us,
ourselves, and everything
in your environment.
We didn't want to
limit our scope
to just on-screen
smartphone notifications.
We used multiple
methods in the research.
We started by
interviewing people.
But then, we also
observed people.
Because notifications are so
contextual and in the moment,
we wanted to observe people
receive notifications
to see what they would do, and
how they would react to them.
We also had group discussions
amongst friends, who
did design exercises together.
And lastly, we synthesized
the data together as a team.
And we held a workshop
later and came up
with ideas that turned
into the features in O.
So what did we learn?
The most striking
observation we made
is that there was this
addiction to phones.
People were bound
to their phones
all day, because
they were afraid they
might miss something important.
Phone notifications were
a major source of stress.
People were very hyper
vigilant to any kind of signal
they could be getting
from their phones,
afraid to miss
something important.
And most notifications were
actually not important to them,
only a few were necessary.
We heard lots of things like
this from our participants.
Denise said, "If I don't have
my phone for two seconds,
I freak out.
What if I miss something?"
And she was a busy lawyer, and
I observed her in her house
the whole day, constantly going
like this, "Where's my phone?
Where's my phone?"
And she'd leave the
room and come back,
looking for her phone.
Just really anxious all
day, just in case her phone
wasn't with her.
And then there's Alice,
who is a professor.
She said, "I wish I could have
something like an Amber Alert
for my parents, ex-husband,
and son's school,
so that those would
override everything else."
She gets lots of notifications
from different sources,
but the only ones she
cares about are these.
And she wishes these would
always override the others.
We observe different coping
strategies from users
to block out all of this noise.
The first one is to
physically put the phone away.
So people would force themselves
to put their phone in a purse,
put it in another room.
Someone even put it in
a box in another room--
just anything to prevent
yourself from checking it.
The other strategy was to not
let the device make noise.
So let it just vibrate, or don't
even let it vibrate at all.
Another strategy was to not
let sources contact you.
That means to block all
notifications from an app.
And the last one
is to do nothing
but be constantly annoyed
every day, and all day.
Steven, he mentioned
a particular
"Social networking app sent
me way too many notifications,
so I deleted the app."
So he got fed up
and deleted the app.
And actually, every
day he uses the service
in a mobile browser,
multiple times a day,
purely just so he wouldn't
receive notifications.
In fact, the pattern
that we're hearing now
is when people get so annoyed
with notifications, whenever
they download a new app,
by default they'll just
block it all, block all
notifications without even
giving it a try.
This is obviously something
we all don't want.
So we need to really be careful
about this cumulative effect
of all of our apps'
notifications.
People often want only some
notifications from an app,
but not all of them.
So even if they want just
one type of notification,
they still receive a
bunch of unwanted ones.
And many people don't
adjust their settings,
even if they know they can.
So even if they know
there's a way to do it,
they might not
know how to do it.
Or it might feel like
a hassle, so they just
live with the problem.
Angie said, "Notifications
are like junk mail.
You can take the time to set
up filters, or just hit delete.
I just deal with them."
She just deals
with it every day.
Stella said, "If you
allow push notifications,
I know there's a way to go
into settings and adjust it,
but I don't know
how to do that."
So what else did we learn?
There were only two
types of notifications
that people needed to know.
The first one-- above all,
notifications from other people
are our most important.
So these include SMS, messaging
apps, emails from people,
phone calls, et cetera.
Anything that came from a
person on the other end, these
were most valued.
Flora said, "Notifications
from other people
are most important.
I always respond."
Those are the only ones
that she pays attention to.
And then, there are
more important people.
So notifications from the
inner circle matter even more.
So these are people
like your spouse,
significant other, parents,
kids, closest friends.
They can reach us at any
time, and we keep channels
open and reserved for them.
Andrew said, "Work emails
and texts from my wife
are the only things that matter.
Basically, things I need to tend
to so I don't get in trouble."
So those are the two
types that he cares about,
above everything else.
The other kind of notification
that's important to people
are reminders for things
that they need to do.
So we observed
people having things
they needed to remember
throughout their day,
like picking up
your dry cleaning,
calling a credit card company
to follow up with an issue,
cleaning a chinchilla cage--
if that applies to you--
setting up a kid's play date,
making new keys for the car.
Things like that, right?
We all have things
like this in our lives,
and people need to
remember these things.
David said, "Sometimes I get
a notification for something
that I actually want to do,
but just not at that moment.
And then I forget
about it later,
because I don't see it again."
And Shelly says, "I know I have
to pick up my dry-cleaning.
But telling me right now
is not going to help me,
it's like nagging.
Tell me when I'm near
the dry cleaner!"
So when a notification
isn't addressed right away,
it's very easy to forget it.
Out of sight, out of mind.
We realize that we need to
make it easier for people
to remember these tasks.
So while this research,
as I mentioned,
was conducted only in
New York and New Jersey,
we've observed similar
patterns in many other studies,
across many
locations, since then.
Whatever topic we're
studying-- from productivity,
to wearables, to driving--
we keep hearing
over and over again
from people about the
stress and the burden of all
the notifications they're
being bombarded with.
So here are some other
locations that we've
done where we've heard similar
patterns across the US,
in many cities, and
internationally.
So based on this research, our
team felt it's important for us
to respect our users'
attention, and to allow
them to have more control.
So this inspired some major
changes in O this year.
Now, here's Rachel
to give you more
details about the features.
[APPLAUSE]
RACHEL GARB: Hi,
I'm Rachel Garb,
and I'm an interaction designer
and manager for the Android UX
team.
The first new feature I want
to talk about is channels.
Show of hands from smartphone
users in the room--
who here has ever
wished that they
could get some of the
notifications from an app,
but not all of them?
That's almost all of you--
yep.
So knowing that, we
definitely wanted
to add support in
the Android system
so that users could have more
granular control over an app's
notifications.
In O, we're
introducing channels,
and here's how it works.
You define a channel for
each notification type
that you want to send,
and then your users
are able to make decisions about
notifications at the channel
level.
Let's look at an example.
Suppose that we are
all the designers
of an app for Crane Air, a
fuss-free corporate airline
that caters to the
frequent flyer.
And here's all our
existing notifications.
We've got a pretty sweet program
for our frequent flyers--
or as we like to call
them, executives.
We have a set of notifications
for our customers
about the points they've
earned, and their status
in the program.
Now, all of these
notifications you see here
have to do with the
executive program.
So let's make a channel and
call it Executive Program.
Now, we occasionally also
offer discounts and deals
to incentivize our customers
to book more flights.
So let's group these
notifications together
in a channel and call
it Discounts and Deals.
Now, when we categorize
notifications into channels,
we want to look
for similar subject
matter and similar
importance to users.
Here, we have a number
of notifications
that could be sent in the
hours and minutes leading up
to the flight, so
they're pretty important.
Let's create a channel for
them called Flight Updates.
And now, with this
example in mind,
let's shift over to how
users experience channels.
The UI design for
channels is optimized
for the number
one most important
use case, which is, "I don't
want this type of notification
from this app."
Now, without channels, any
support for this use case
has to come from within
the app, with settings
to block notifications by type.
Now, how does a user find
out if an app provides this?
They have to open the app
and look at the settings.
And it's not like all apps are
going to do it the same way.
But a lot of the time,
there won't be any way
to block notifications by type.
And at that point,
the user has to decide
what they're going to do.
They can ban the app from
sending any notifications
at all, they could uninstall
the app, or just live with it.
And none of these are ideal.
But with channels,
it's a different story.
One that's straightforward
and consistent.
Let's check out the UI.
Now, we at Crane Air know
that a segment of our users
love to celebrate when they earn
points or reach a new status.
So whenever they land, we notify
them about how many points
they earned on the
flight, and how close they
are to the next status level.
But, maybe not all users want
to be notified like this.
Some might not want
any notifications,
except the ones that are
essential to functioning
in their daily lives.
And they know that they
can get this information
in their monthly statement,
they're fine waiting for it.
So to stop this type
of notification,
all a user has to do
is touch and hold it,
which lets them see the channel.
And then, they turn off
this switch and tap Done.
No more executive program
notifications from Crane Air,
but they'll still keep
getting the others,
like those handy flight updates.
Now, our aim with channels is
to make it possible for users
to get most, if not all, of
their notification control
needs met in line, or one
step away in Settings.
Now, in Settings,
users can decide
to block all
notifications from an app.
And new for O, an app can
show a dot on its icon
when it has notifications
waiting for a user.
But if the user doesn't ever
want to see a dot for that app,
they can prevent the
app from showing it.
Users can see all of
the channels at a glance
and decide which ones they want.
They can view and edit
settings for a given channel--
more on that to come.
And if the app wants to provide
other settings beyond what's
here, the app can have
a link for the users
back to a screen in the app.
This approach, bringing
more notification controls
into the system, makes
the user experience
more convenient and consistent.
So that is an
overview of channels.
And next, I'd like to talk
about the new behavior
model for notifications
in O. And I'll
start with the research
that informed it.
Some people are putting up with
unwanted notification behavior,
because they're reluctant
to use settings-- you
heard about this from Julie.
So the opportunity
here was to make
it easier for users to
understand and control
notification behavior.
Now, let's compare the
current behavior model
with the new one for O.
In the current model,
the app developer uses a field
called Priority, and sets
a priority level for
each notification.
That level maps to a set of
behaviors, and some of them
are customizable by the app.
For example, if you choose
priority level high as the app
developer, you can have your
notification make sound or not.
You can have it vibrate or not,
you can have it peek or not.
It's a lot for a user to follow.
In the new model,
priority is deprecated.
And instead, the app developer
sets an importance level
for each of their
channels, rather than
for individual notifications.
And there's fewer
customizations that the app
can make on that behavior.
Here, you see the inner
workings of priority levels.
I won't read this out to
you, but let's compare it
with importance levels.
As you can see, we've gone
down from five to four levels
and reduced what
can be customized.
We are intentionally trading
flexibility for simplicity
so that users have a better
shot at understanding
what the heck is going on.
We're letting go of
allowing each notification
to behave differently so
that we can guarantee users
that all notifications
from the same channel
behave the same way.
In the current model, a user
can control an app's behavior
but has no insight whatsoever
into the app's intentions
as they're making decisions.
But in the new model, the
user gets a clear picture
of app behavior as
they make decisions.
So it's the difference
between, I can make sure
that this app won't be
able to do X, versus,
I can see this channel
does X, but I'm
going to have a do Y instead.
I'll show you what I
mean by comparing the UI.
In the current UI, if Show
Silently here is turned on,
then it's predictable.
But otherwise, the
user has no clue
how notifications from
the app will behave.
In the new UI, the
user just needs
to look at the
Importance setting to see
how the channel will behave.
And if they don't like it, they
can choose a different setting.
In this new model, Android
creates a setting screen
for every channel
from every app.
This is the place where
users go to see and control
its behavior.
The main settings are to
block the channel and change
importance.
If the importance
level is high enough,
the user has sound and
vibration options, too.
And there's more
advanced options.
Now, you can also optionally
provide a brief description
of what the channel does,
if it's not obvious,
so that users can make
more informed decisions.
If your app already offers
channel-like behavior,
please leverage Android
Solution so that users
don't run into the
situation where
there's a discrepancy between
an app and system settings.
You can link to the
system settings screen,
either at the channel
or the app level.
And if you want to
offer channel controls
beyond what the system offers--
for example, letting users
specify notification and email
preferences in the same
place in your app--
you can have a link back
to your app settings.
And that's an overview of
the new importance model.
Next, I'll turn
it over to Justin
to talk about other
new things for O.
[APPLAUSE]
JUSTIN BARBER: Thanks, Rachel.
I'm Justin Barber, and I'm a
visual designer on Android.
And I have to start with an
apology, because many of you
probably showed up for
this session hoping
for a Justin Bieber concert.
And it's not
happening, but I still
have some pretty interesting
stuff to talk about.
So visual hierarchy
is the focus of O.
And if you remember
last year in N,
we completely redesigned
notification templates
to become more flexible,
modern, much cleaner.
And the new features in
O that I'll be covering
were really built
on the foundation
that we set in N. And also
on Julie's amazing research.
So that's where I'll start,
with the research insights that
really led to our approach in O.
So the first insight
was that people
are overloaded
with notifications,
and it's hard to find
the important ones.
I'm pretty sure we've
all been here before.
And in Julie's
research, we uncovered
that users were
building associations
to determine what was
important for them.
So if the phone made a
certain vibration tone,
or they saw a certain
color of light blinking,
or they'd see a color
in their notification--
they were making associations
to determine whether or not
this was important enough
for them to spend time on.
But that can be frustrating,
misleading, and above all,
time consuming.
So our goal for O was
to present notifications
in a way that helps users
sift through the noise.
Not just to build
more associations,
but to build a
consistency and a trust.
You should know where the
important stuff's going to be,
before you have to
go looking for it.
The second most
important insight
that led to our
approach was that people
are the VIP notifications.
In absolutely all scenarios,
who is more important than what
or when.
So the opportunity
here is pretty simple,
make people notifications
VIPs of the drawer.
People matter the most and
notifications is really
a communications
hub, so we really
want to emphasize
that in this space.
So as I mentioned
before, N focused
on individual
notification templates.
And in O, we've zoomed
out to kind of see
the bigger picture and
how they all fit together
in one experience,
specifically by improving
the hierarchy of notifications
that appear in the drawer.
We did this by designating
four different types
of notifications and
four different buckets
for them, represented
by these yellow blocks.
Before I get into the detail
of each different bucket,
I'll give you the
high level overview.
So the first bucket
is for major ongoing.
This is things
like a phone call.
The next is people to people,
like a message from a friend.
The third is general
notifications,
the best of which
are timely reminders.
And the fourth are
By The Way, or BTW.
These are the four buckets
and notification types,
and how they're organized
within the drawer.
And the purpose of
this is to ensure
that notifications most critical
to read first are shown first.
It also creates consistency.
When you pull down the drawer to
find that specific notification
you're looking
for, you'll already
know which area to be looking at
because you'll become familiar
with these sections.
So we're enabling users
to build associations
through this ordering.
And lastly, we're going to
be ranking notifications
within each section.
This means if you have
two message notifications,
they're not going to be
separated by something
else in the middle.
They'll always appear
together, so it
will be a lot easier to scan
the notification drawer.
So now you have a big
picture, let's drill down
into the details of each bucket,
starting with the first one.
Major ongoing notifications
are really for time
sensitive content users
should actively be aware of.
This is like a phone call,
driving directions, timer,
music.
And as the developers send
this type of notification,
you need to be
running a foreground
service with importance
higher than MIN,
or using a MediaStyle
with MediaSession
for music notification.
And this type of
content is for content
that's using device resources
that directly impacts real life
context.
And the things that match that
is a really, really short list.
The type of
notification will rarely
be appearing in
the user's drawer,
because the context
that requires
it is a very rare situation.
So in N, this is kind of what
these types of notification
looks like, right?
They're not very visually
distinguished, they
don't necessarily always appear
at the top of the drawer,
they can be lost amidst
the other notifications.
And if you wanted
the proper prominence
to really gain that
association for the user,
you had to go with
customization,
which led to inconsistency with
the rest of the notifications.
So in O, what we're
doing is we're
pulling that color from the
app and filling the background
with it, and guaranteeing a
top spot in the notification
drawer.
So these will always
appear at the very top.
But again, because
they're so prominent,
misusing this type of
notification for something
it's not meant for will
be very obvious to users.
And with the channels that
Rachel just described,
it'll be really easy for them to
block this type of notification
if it doesn't align with
what it's really meant to be.
Falling into this
category is also music.
So in N, you can see that
the media template is
the most different
template that we
have compared to all
the others, but it still
feels really generic.
And it doesn't
really look different
from other notifications.
So in O, we've integrated
the album artwork
into the notification, and drawn
out the most prominent colors
for the background
and as an accent.
The result is a beautiful,
lively notification
that really
celebrates the artwork
and the artists behind the
music that we really love.
And I found myself pulling
down the notification drawer
as I listen to music,
just to see what kind
of colors that song generates.
Now, for the next section--
people to people.
This is really for
content from a person,
like a message or a missed call.
And as Julie mentioned, people
are the VIP notifications.
So we're going to put them
right at the top of the drawer
in the number one position,
since major ongoing's going
to be pretty rare.
To get this type
of notification,
you should be using
MessagingStyle
with direct reply or
attaching a contact to it.
So as it stands today,
a message notification
is really not that valuable
until you interact with it.
There's, like, one
line of the message,
so you don't know if it's worth
actually expanding and reading.
And then, you still have
to make the decision
if you should reply to it.
And you may not be able
to reply to it directly
within the drawer, you have
to jump out of the drawer.
So it's really just
not that valuable.
So in O, we've made one
really subtle change
that has actually made a really
big impact on the messaging
experience.
And that is that we're
exposing more lines of content
in the collapsed state
of the notification.
So now, you can read up to
three lines of the message
without having to spend the
time expanding the notification
and deciding what you
want to do with it.
And we're continuing to invest
heavily in this area of focus.
And we're looking forward to
making even more improvements,
especially around direct
reply, coming soon.
This next bucket is for
general notifications.
And the best of which-- as
we documented in material
guidelines, and Julie's
research backs up--
is really meant for well-timed
and informative task reminders.
And in O, there's no
behavior or visual change
in the representation
of these notifications.
But it does play into
the next bucket of BTW.
And today, there are
a lot of notifications
being sent into this
general bucket that really
should be sent in O as a BTW.
BTWs, By The Way
notifications, are
meant for contextual or
informative, but non-urgent,
content.
We heard a lot of stories
from Julie's research
about how people
felt so overwhelmed.
If content in the
drawer isn't urgent,
it should be sent as a BTW.
Things like weather
updates or traffic,
or suggestions and promotions.
So earlier in this
presentation, Rachel
used Crane Air as an example
of how to organize your apps'
notifications into channels.
I remember there are
three different channels--
Executive Program,
Flight Updates,
and Discounts and Deals.
And that last category
of Discounts and Deals
is an excellent
example of what should
be sent as a BTW notification.
And it's pretty
simple to send one,
you just need to set the
importance of the notification
to MIN.
So in N, the visual
representation
of these notifications
is pretty equal with all
the other notifications.
The only difference was
a slightly different
colored background.
It's a pretty heavyweight
presentation for content that's
actually very lightweight.
That's bothersome to users,
it takes up a lot of space.
So what we've done in O
is we've taken the app
name and the first line
of the notification,
and simplified that
down into a single line.
So the new
presentation is really
meant to feel
lightweight so that users
don't feel bothered by them.
They don't need to manage them,
because they're out of the way.
And it's OK if they
can glance at it
and don't want to take
action on it right now.
You can also set your
notification to automatically
expire so that users also don't
have that burden of having
to manage them, as well.
The advantage of
this is that instead
of risking annoying
your users by sending
a notification in
that general bucket,
you can send it
as a BTW instead.
This way, you don't
have to hurt users'
trust by risking something.
You can just put it
in the BTW section.
Also, the full
functionality still remains.
So if the user taps
on this BTW, it
expands the full notification,
you get all the color.
And if the notification
has actions with it,
those will appear as well.
So when you put it
all together, it
comes together really nicely.
You can actually tell a
very intentional order
within the drawer.
And when we compare
that with N, that's
when you can really see
the differences come out.
If you squint your
eyes and look at N,
which is on the left in
the black phone frame,
you can't really tell which
notification is which,
at a glance.
But if you look at
O, it's really clear.
You can see the major
ongoing at the top,
you can see the
BTWs at the bottom.
You can even kind of tell that
it's a message notification,
because it's taller
than the rest.
You can also see in
N how when there's
an overflow of notifications,
those notifications
got stacked behind the
ones that were visible.
This doesn't match up super
well with the spatial model
of the full width notifications.
So in O, we've improved
that spatial model
and made it feel
much more unified.
A really beautiful animation,
and the point of this,
is to correlate the
notifications of icons
of how they appear
in the status bar,
with the notifications that
they are in the drawer.
And again--
[APPLAUSE]
Yeah, you can clap.
Pretty cool, right?
[APPLAUSE]
This is something we're
really, really proud of.
And again, it wouldn't
have been possible
without those template changes
that we made in N, right?
So we're taking steps to
unify the whole experience.
You can also see how instead
of stacking at the bottom,
overflow notifications
fit into a shelf.
And we have a really
beautiful experience going on.
I'll just let it
play one more time.
Oof.
[LAUGHTER]
All right, so this
is the last feature
I'll be covering pretty briefly.
And that's snoozing.
And this feature came
directly out of user research.
So the insight was that
people need to remember
the things they need to do.
And today, you only
have two options
if you can't deal with a
notification right now.
You can either dismiss
the notification
and count on your memory--
which if you're me, never
works, ask my wife--
or, you can leave the
notification in the shade.
But it can get lost amidst a ton
of other notifications, right?
It's either, or.
So our opportunity was
to give users more ways
to do this in the drawer.
So let's say you're
in a meeting,
and you get a text from a
friend asking you about dinner.
Now, you're in the meeting,
so you can't reply right away.
But you know as soon as
you leave the meeting,
your mind's already going
to be on to the next task,
and you're not going
to remember to reply.
So instead of letting
the notification linger
in the drawer or just
dismissing it altogether,
you can snooze it.
And this is how.
You can do a
partial swipe, which
reveals two different icons.
You'll notice it's an
additional icon to the gear
that we introduced in N. And
this is the button for snooze.
So if you tap this
icon, the notification
will automatically be snoozed.
And you'll get a
confirmation of this snooze,
with an option to undo
it if you need to.
So snoozing the
notification will
set it to come back
at that set duration,
with the exact same
interruptive qualities that it's
sent with as before.
So if it made a vibration tone
when it came in the first time,
and you snooze it, it will
vibrate again the second time
when it comes back.
So if you want a different
time than one hour,
you can just tap that arrow.
And you'll get a few
different options
to change that duration.
And the option that
you select then
will then be set as
the default duration
the next time you
snooze a notification.
Pretty simple.
That's what we have to show you
for the new notifications in O.
And if you're interested
in finding out
even more, especially from
a more detailed engineering
perspective, there's
an earlier talk--
What's New in
Notifications, Launcher
Icons, and Shortcuts-- that
we'd encourage you to check out.
We're really excited
about these improvements
and believe that
these features are not
only beneficial to
users, but will also
increase the quality
of engagement
through apps Thanks so much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]